[Musica]
quanto ero al giorno spendete sui social
te marco io moltissime in realtà esiste
una funzione sulle impostazioni del
nostro telefono che ci permette di
controllare quante ore passiamo al
giorno sul nostro telefono controllavo
ieri io sono out ore e 30 minuti in un
giorno soltanto e tre ore e 14 minuti
solamente su instagram
se penso a 10 o anche solo cinque anni
fa questi tre ore e 14 minuti le avrei
spesa leggendo un libro studiando per un
esame
parlando al telefono con un amico o
magari anche in andata nella spesa cosa
che ora non faccio nemmeno più di
persona ma utilizza un'applicazione per
farmi arrivare il cibo a casa ed è come
se il mondo di oggi potessimo definire
la nostra giornata in base
all'applicazione che utilizziamo da
quando mi sveglio che nella sera canada
a dormire alle 6 30 del mattino apro
istria non controllo la xe commenti
controllo le email
vado a fare yoga e per mettermi nella
lista della mia classe deve usare
un'applicazione quando vento abiti
vintage su internet utilizza
un'applicazione per controllare le
vendite e le visite se sono stanca e
stressata utilizza un'applicazione di
meditazione guidata alla sera ordino il
cibo con un'altra applicazione e molto
spesso quando guardo la tv alcune tv
shows in america non sono già presenti
in tv e quindi bisogna scaricare il
network in cui vanno in onda sul
telefono e con un'applicazione si
connette nello schermo del telefono alla
tv
siamo a più di dieci applicazioni in
sole 24 ore quindi le app quanto di
influenzano nella tua vita quotidiana le
applicazioni influenzano tantissimo
scandiscono e definiscono la mia
giornata lavorativa
sto però creare un certo tipo di
equilibrio di distanza emotiva tra la
mia vita privata è quello che sono i
social media che sono uno strumento di
lavoro
molte persone però sento la pressione di
dover essere e apparire in un certo modo
sui social media ossia a postare
determinate foto con abiti che costano
molto fare dei viaggi di lusso e questa
tensione è talmente alta che
obbligate a cancellare insegue dal
proprio telefono per 24 48 ore per
eliminare questa sì modo che sono
costrette a non controllare
l'applicazione il discorso del papa
francesco del ted 2019 è stato per me
fonte di ispirazione e di partenza come
analizzare i cambiamenti del social
media sulla mia identità il papa ricorda
che la vita scorre attraverso le
relazioni che l'esistenza di ognuno di
noi è legata a quella degli altri
quindi la vita non è tempo che passa ma
tempo di incontro
l'incontro di cui parla il papa sta
diventando sempre di più virtuale è un
incontro che al giorno d'oggi si sta
materializzando con un post con un
commento con un tag con un follow con un
fallo con uno share
anche le emozioni vengono sostituite da
delle moggi da questi piccoli disegni
che rappresentano delle faccine secondo
voi un emozione si può scrivere
bè sempre che con l'em oggi possiamo
comunicare uno stato d'animo ed arrivare
dritti al cuore
secondo voi un'email d'amore si può
tradurre in una chat con delle faccine
sembra che le oggi nella fase del
corteggiamento abbiano un ruolo più
efficace di un antidepressivo
perché sono semplici e dirette veloci
sono delle vere e proprie micro emozioni
che hanno il potere di annullare
l'attesa addirittura è stato grado con
dizionario online delle moggi e facebook
ha creato una statistica delle moggi
utilizzate per paese sembri che l'italia
al primo posto delle moggi romantiche
google oggi della faccina che piange da
ridere è diventata secondo il
vocabolario di oxford del 2015
la parola dell'anno quindi una non
parola diventa la parola dell'anno
google nel 2016 ha creato 13 e moggi che
rappresentano la donna nel mondo del
lavoro
proprio per creare una parità dei sessi
anche nel mondo virtuale
quindi accanto alle moggi uomo dott
oggi uomo dottore oggi troviamo anche le
moggi donna dottoressa le moggi
addirittura ad oggi con alcune app
possono essere personalizzate possono
ricreare la nostra ai nostri tratti
somatici le nostre espressioni del
nostro viso quindi con le moggi possiamo
veramente toccare quello che noi siamo e
diventiamo in questo mondo digitale dei
social media esistono anche delle entità
digitali umanizzate ossia degli esteri
che sono digitali ma che hanno le
sembianze di un essere umano ma la
differenza è che non sono reali
se non esistono mi riferisco a lei il
suo nome è il nome chi l'ha lei la prima
entità digitalizzata molto famosa su
instagram ovvero avatar
lei come me è basata los angeles e da
un'influenza a tutti gli effetti in
quanto marchi di moda importantissimi
l'assumono per postare immagini video
con i loro prodotti sul suo instagram
lei però lo ricorda sui posti cia am not
a human being non sono un essere umano
lei un'immagine prodotto a computer in
inglese se dicessi g ai computer genova
è un prodotto creato in post produzione
lei è la prima ad essere diventata così
conosciuta ma c'è un gruppo molto
crescente di itunes sia di intelligenza
artificiale che sta prendendo piede sui
social media per darvi alcuni numeri sul
nome chi la ha un team di 12 persone
esperti di marketing grafica e tecnici
che la disegnano la creano la vestono e
decidono cosa farle dire nel 2017 questo
team ha ottenuto un investimento di
oltre 6 milioni di dollari per creare
quello che è l'eroe me chi la dà un
fondo che quell'anno è stato quotato per
oltre 2 milioni di dollari ma secondo
voi questa entità digitale che sembra un
essere umano ma che non lo è
è reale mi è capitato di lavorare con
uno di questi digital avatar
dell'assurdità stava nel fatto che sui
set fotografici venivano utilizzate
delle modelle umane come delle vere e
proprie controfigure venivano utilizzate
per indossare i vestiti e realizzare il
servizio fotografico poi nella fase di
post produzione 3d veniva realizzata
l'identità di questi digital avatar
i digital avatar non sono reali la loro
influenza è reale il michela e molto
influente sul socie stata una delle
prime addirittura possiede un profilo
wikipedia wi lly michela supporta anche
delle cause civile e sul social
addirittura un fidanzato e una rivale
tant'è che in un post avevo condiviso un
emozione disse che quando si lascia con
il suo fidanzato
l'unica cosa che la faceva sentire forte
era fare lo yoga il michela esprime
anche i suoi sogni
quali sono i suoi sogni le vuole essere
di più di quello che i suoi fan si
aspettano da lei lei vuole essere tutto
nel michela quindi rappresenta veramente
questo limbo generazionale tra virtuale
e reale il michela rappresenta questo
senso di perfezione che la generazione z
ad oggi espira la generazione z alla
generazione ze quella generazione che è
nata nel 1997 l'anno della nascita di
instagram le tendenze non sono più
definite solamente dalle case di moda di
milano a londra e parigi ma dalle
ragazze normali che postano foto su
instagram che condividono la loro vita
sui social media
la moda è quindi diventata accessibile a
tutti non più qualcosa di limitato ad un
gruppo ristretto di persone
i social media hanno cambiato i canoni
di bellezza magari anche senza che ce ne
accorgiamo volevo portare appunto alcuni
esempi
lei è vice chi una drag queen star che è
stata riconosciuta grazie al talent show
di gruppo e vogue america ora la
considera una vera e propria icona di
stile
lei invece a lei ha 28 anni l'ho
conosciuta di persona a londra un mese
fa per un lavoro new york ed è la prima
modella plus size ad essere utilizzata
in una campagna di victoria's secrets
consiglio dell'azienda due anni prima
aveva dichiarato che non avrebbe mai
usato modelle plus size and transgender
ma io minimal che a livello di struttura
fisica e di altezza è una vera e propria
modella da passerella ma la vitiligine
dalla testa e piedi
l'ultimo esempio a me molto caro in
quanto l'ho conosciuta a new york e andy
amour un'attrice transgender conosciuta
per il suo tv show post che è stata
nominata nuovo volto della moda a
settembre a new york durante e dei riff
awards in questa arena virtuale abbiamo
due tendenze
da una parte abbiamo una ricerca
dell'autenticità nel cosiddetto no
filter dove gli inestetismi e le
imperfezioni diventano come qualcosa da
esibire e da asta gare stanno nascendo
asta come diversi di inclusivi di skin
condition
in questo caso vorrei fa riferimento a
un'esperienza personale quello con l'ump
top model melanie god is modella ha
parzialmente ceca che soffre di alopecia
e di una malattia genetica che non gli
ha permesso alla formazione delle ossa
dei denti e delle cartilagini lavorando
con lei ho ritrovato e riscoperto a lei
un forte senso di auto accettazione di
consapevolezza di fiducia in se stessa
le quali mi hanno messo fortemente a mio
agio
rimasi colpita quando il giornalista sul
7 gli che se melanie che cos'è per te la
bellezza e rispose è la vulnerabilità
nella forza la forza nella vulnerabilità
la purezza di essere fortemente te
stessa in ogni momento della vita
il social media oltre a modificare i
canoni di bellezza in modo in cui
facciamo la moda ea definire la nostra
giornata hanno anche cambiato il modo di
comuni
volevo parlare di tre per forme che sono
le più importanti le più utilizzate i
podcast youtube è in programma il
podcast è una nuova forma di canale
radio che possiamo ascoltare un esperto
parla di determinate tematiche o per
intervistare personaggio noto per un
totale di 20 o 45 minuti ma accessibile
direttamente dal nostro telefono tramite
un'applicazione sono stata ospite di un
podcast qualche mese fa molto famoso a
los angeles e in australia
fondato da due donne che parlano e
appunto danno consigli su come diventare
imprenditrici sui social media
mi hanno fatto un sacco di domande sulla
mia storia se come ho cominciato la mia
carriera su quali sono le cose che sono
difficili per me quelle che mi piacciono
di più e ho trovato questa piattaforma
molto efficace per approfondire
tematiche sociali e politiche molto più
che un articolo di giornale scritto ho
stampato sicuramente la piattaforma più
importante per quanto riguarda video
musicali comici oppure anche tutorial di
moda e di bellezza un esempio di talent
che è riuscito ad entrare nel mondo
della televisione a partire dal mondo
digitale è lì leasing lily è canadese di
nazionalità indiana e il secondo forbes
è una delle youtubers più pagati al
mondo con il visite di un solo video di
youtube
lei ha guadagnato 10.5 milioni dollari
quest'anno è miss le ha dato un canale
televisivo proprio per lei una
trasmissione creata per lei è la prima
donna è la prima donna di colore a
presentare un live nation sia uno show
che va in onda dopo l'undici sera
posizione che da sempre nella storia
della televisione americana era
ricoperta da uomini oltre 40 anni
insegnano resta comunque la piattaforma
più utilizzata per condividere tutti i
tipi di contenuti e come ricorda la
modella e attrice inglese come delle
vini in un'intervista recente dice se
non fosse per instagram
io non avrei la carriera che ho io mi
ritrovo molto in questa fase in quanto
se non fosse prince the gun non sarei
qui non farei quello che faccio e volevo
chiudere dicendo che quando i miei fans
miei amici e le persone che mi seguono
mi chiedono ma come si fa a farcela se i
social media come si fa ad avere un
lavoro con instagram
io non so mai cosa dire perché non c'è
una strada precisa non ci sono regole
non
serve avere una laurea o un diploma ci
sono due aspetti fondamentali che sono
avere fiducia in se stessi e avere
un'idea se si crede che la propria idea
è forte abbastanza da poter essere
comunicata al mondo allora abbiamo una
voce il social media il digital non è
altro che un mare di queste voci tutte
diverse e tutte imperfette ma allo
stesso tempo di grande valore
quindi il motivo per cui si riesce ad
emergere è per avere una voce unica ed è
finita sui social possiamo essere quello
che vogliamo possiamo essere attori
ballerini cantanti influencer questo è
bello soprattutto per le persone che
fino ad oggi non hanno avuto la
possibilità di dimostrare la loro
creatività il social mica è uno
strumento dove noi diventiamo creatori
diventiamo creatori di una cultura è uno
strumento assolutamente verticale nello
stesso momento diventa anche orizzontale
per la sua democraticità democraticità
da uno strumento che ha delle
responsabilità and powerful e
rivoluzionario il mio lavoro mi permette
di parlare per immagini mi sono
ritrovata in una città come los angeles
ca ta vault catapultata nel mondo
virtuale
non ho fatto altro che considerare
questo mondo virtuale come un mare dove
navigare in libertà esprimere la mia
creatività e trovare anche una platea di
persone che sapessero apprezzarmi quale
sono state le parole chiavi della mia
vita
b creati e mostrano al mondo
senza dimenticare che c'è una differenza
tra essere e apparire tra virtuale e
reale
[Applauso]
[Musica]